San Diego comic-con is just a few days
away with a preview happening tomorrow
as expected there's going to be a ton of
new releases and information coming out
leading up to and during San Diego
comic-con I'm going to be covering
comic-con throughout the whole entire
weekend giving you guys news and updates
as soon as I can so be sure to subscribe
to my channel if you'd like to receive
them if you're not aware Marvel is not
really having any presence there at this
comic-con so it's really going to be all
about DC which is really nice because
you can tell that they're really trying
to revamp the DC EU and it honestly
brings hope and I know that's funny but
I think a lot of people have kind of
given up on the DC EU but everything
that they've been doing to try to make
it better it seems like it could work
we've got three really big movies coming
up and that's Wonder Woman 1984 Aquaman
and Shazam so throughout the week and
over the weekend expect to get a lot
more reveals about these movies and just
a lot more info on them in general and
we do have some trailers coming out we
know that the Aquaman trailer is going
to come out this Saturday and yesterday
we got a first theatrical poster for
Aquaman and today we actually have an
awesome new San Diego Comic Con magazine
cover
courtesy of den of geek den of geek
released this cover today that actually
gives us a first look at several major
characters including ocean master with
his helmet on now we've seen form aka
ocean master before but he didn't have
his helmet on and it's really nice to
get a look at it because it shows us
that it's actually very accurate to how
it is in the comics in fact I think the
only difference here is that in the
comics the chin is a little pointy ER
but besides that it's dead on with this
we also see Dolph Lundgren as Nereus
Willem Dafoe as volcko Yaya Abdul Mateen
in his Black Manta uniform and we also
get our first look
at the trench the trench are an ocean
dwelling race of evil creatures that
fight Aquaman and Mira and the comics
they have crazy razor-sharp teeth that
can actually puncture Aquaman's skin
along with that if they do bite you
it'll cause a mild paralysis they're a
super evil race that only focuses on one
thing food they have a king and a queen
and in the comics Aquaman actually takes
on the king and since they are in the
film maybe we'll get a little clip of
that in the movie I like how they made
them look here not too far off from how
they look in the comics super evil I'm
satisfied when DC's film producer Peter
Safran was talking about the cover art
he said the inspiration behind this
original work was those classic comic
book covers that gave the reader a look
at the characters involved in the story
and also hints of and a feel for their
worlds it was commissioned by James Wan
in the very early R&D stages of
pre-production as he was beginning to
define the worlds in which our film
would live it was not originally
intended to be a one-sheet but we all
loved it so much that we had the idea to
transform it into a photorealistic
version and use it as a poster I really
liked the idea and I really liked this
cover I think the characters are done
really well and I'm really excited for
the trailer to come out this Saturday so
let me know what you all think of this
cover did you imagine the characters in
a different way or do you like how they
were done let me know in the comments
below be sure to hit that like button
and again I will be covering comic-con
throughout the whole entire weekend
getting you guys the latest news and
updates as fast as I can so be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]
[Music]